eat in a day in Qatar und ein Tipp von
mir setzt euch niemals im Flieger neben
die Toiletten den ganzen flugüber hat
echt übel gerochen während des Fluges
gab es Pasta ganz kalten Reis und einen
richtig leckeren Pudding wir sind
angekommen in DOA und die Stadt ist so
instagrammable Zimmer ist auch ein Traum
mit einem heftigen Ausblick aber darum
soll es ja nicht gehen wir haben uns
erstmal past dena gegönnt das ist zwar
nicht typisch katarisch aber wir hatten
richtig Lust drauf mir hat so ein
bisschen die Vanillenote gefehlt wenn
ihr wissen möchtet was es alles im
Supermarkt gibt dann schreibt es mir
gerne und ich mache euch ein paar zwei
daraus ich habe mir auf jeden Fall
dieses Eis gekt das war richtig lecker
und hat Mund geknistert Abend haben wir
uns auch noch Datteln gegönnt die wir
noch da hatten und später sind wir noch
palästinensisch essen gegangen Leute das
war so lecker es hat geschmeckt wie bei
meiner schwiegerm es gab ganz
traditionell mansf das ist ein
Lammgericht mit Reis und Joghurt
unfassbar lecker und musschenchen
selbstgemachtes Brot mit ganz viel Sumak
Zwiebeln und Hähnchen ich habe mich
gefühlt als würde ich bei hamsers Mama
Essen danach haben wir ein
palästinensisches Dessert gegessen
nämlich knäffe die Türken kennen das als
künäffe aber auf die nablusart schmeckt
das einfach unfassbar gut viele haben
gefragt wo der Spot ist ich schreib es
euch hier auf und so ist der Abend zu